[Music]  the only reason someone's scared to fail  is because they're scared of people  seeing them fail if there was nobody  watching you'd be doing true you just  got to realize that nobody's opinions  you know what you should do you should  fail so you can see how not scary it is  because every time of course nobody  gives a [ __ ] about yourself you got time  nobody gives a [ __ ] that you're failing  what are they gonna make a snarky  comment your emotions are wrapped up in  other people's opinions my perception of  what they think you're insecure yeah but  we're gonna build up and [ __ ] realize  I'm insecure and you're gonna build up  and [ __ ] not be insecure I appreciate  it